[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'effervescence des jeux olympiques a
frappé le vélodrome nationale ce
mercredi 13 septembre pour le vivre
pleinement l'annoncé officielle du cio
depuis lima saint quentin en yvelines
avait organisé une journée spéciale
dédiée aux valeurs de l'olympisme
parmi les temps forts 850 enfants sont
venus de toute la région pour participer
à une quarantaine d'ateliers sportifs
l'escrimeur pas on n'a jamais fait le
golfe
wood ce que j'ai fait c'est du mini golf
c'est bien parce que j'ai jamais fait
que je vais découvrir que j'ai déjà fait
mais du coup bah ça va permettre de
m'améliorer
les enfants ont également pu rencontrer
une dizaine de champions français parmi
eux thomas levet ancien golfeur
professionnel
le sportif a animé des mini ateliers sur
le thème du golfe
moi quand je commence j'ai commencé le
sport c'est en rencontrant des champions
parce que tout d'un quotidien as j'ai
rencontré un tel qu'est ce qui fait
qu'en sport tu commences à te quitte y
intéresse un petit peu plus tu regardes
les résultats et puis tu dis à tes
parents dit moi papa j'aimerais bien
faire du judo par exemple j'aimerais
bien soir du golfe mais les champions
bas ça ça aide toujours à passer le cap
en se disant tiens je vais le faire le
sport j'essaie j'aime bien et allons-y
en fin de journée après le départ des
enfants plus de 500 supporters
tricolores sont venus assister en direct
à l'annoncé du cio via des écrans géants
installés pour l'occasion
bah oui c'est important ça descend temps
que paris attend les jo donc je pense
que c'est important de célébrer tous
ensemble cet événement aujourd'hui être
présent
pour cette première échéance je dirais
de confirmation de gio oui c'est
important on est acteur tous autant
qu'on est à chaque niveau donc oui après
de longues minutes d'attentes le verdict
tombe enfin paris officiellement
désignée ville hôte pour les jeux
olympiques de 2024 par le si tu es dans
l'action extraordinaire une réaction de
joie une réaction de joie
les jeux olympiques sont à paris en 2024
c'est officiellement officiel maintenant
et là c'est vraiment une explosion de
joie on l'a senti lors de l' annonce est
maintenant l aventure commence une
aventure commence c'est une aventure
historique et ça va être passionnant de
vivre cette période
les supporters présents au vélodrome
national espère maintenant vibrer dans
un peu moins de 7 ans avec des médailles
d'or françaises